we're going Austin yay we're meeting up
the big wood girls because we're gonna
do a panel out there and meet some of
you guys
[Music]
we're so excited to have them come up on
stage now so let me introduce a big moon
podcast come on guys the girls and I are
so excited to actually see people show
up it was so awesome because we had this
really deep conversation about the power
of vulnerability and it was really
awesome because a lot of the audience
members were actually like joining in on
the conversation and they were even just
really deep moments where I actually
even cried I don't know it was just a
really beautiful panel and I feel like
we really connected to the people that
were there afterwards we had a meet and
greet and so we actually got to hug
every single person and hear from them
what they felt and what they took away
from the panel and it was just so sweet
and so awesome to actually get to see
them and hear from them and get some
connect with them on an even deeper
level oh my goodness
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that was me for like the first week
without like I don't know what to do I
feel like scared that I'm gonna break
him or he's gonna break something on me
he's surprisingly heavy yeah like after
only like a minute I'm like okay
here's Timmy
and that pretty much concluded our time
in Austin after the panel the girls went
their separate ways and we made our way
up to Dallas but before we continue on
our trip huge shout out to athletic
greens for sponsoring today's video now
one habit I've added to my morning
routine is to drink ag1 by athletic
greens each morning as I get older I'm
looking more into vitamins let's go get
down
so I'm getting older and I'm looking to
vitamins supplements to keep my body
feeling its best but taking so many
different supplements sometimes can be
hard on your stomach it's definitely
hard to keep up with and who knows if
it's even working well together so I
like ag-1 because it's nine Health
Products and one nutritional drink you
basically get the equivalent of a
multivitamin minerals and probiotics and
so much more to keep your body in Peak
Performance and I'm a dad now so Peak
Performance is needed every day all
right so the way it works step one put
eight to twelve ounces of water into
your Shaker step two scoop one or add
one serving of age you one to step three
shake it up
it's actually really really good I don't
know what kind of fruit it is but it's
definitely got a fruity flavor to it I
don't know what kind of nuts it is but
it's definitely got a Nutty flavor to it
so if you like fruits and nuts this is
great ag1 is super easy to add to your
daily routine it's just one scoop once a
day it takes me less than one minute
every day to lead a healthy lifestyle
and to support my immunity this is great
because I'm super busy with Luca these
days and as you can see in this video we
are currently traveling so athletic
greens even has these travel packs that
you can take on your trips so anyway I
can simplify my nutrition is a plus if
you're looking for a comprehensive
all-in-one foundation for your nutrition
check out ag1 by athletic greens tap my
link to get a one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D3 K2 and five travel
packs free with your first purchase you
can't put a price tag on your health all
right what's up guys so we have left
Austin the panel was a success I watched
from the the stands sad audience
perspective of the whole thing and it
was fantastic yeah it was a very nice
panel and very informative and I felt
like whoever attended it I think
definitely walked away with something
special what was your confirmation from
people that were there that they walked
away loving it because we got to do a
meet and greet after and they were just
telling us how they really loved the
panel but they really love our podcast
it was really awesome it's always the
best getting to meet people that are
behind the camera so it's always awesome
but yeah so now we are many many miles
away from Austin we are actually on the
way to Dallas and I think we're getting
closer to Dallas than we are to Austin
so we're more than halfway through our
trip um I think we're past Waco too so
actually we're only an hour out from
Dallas one hour 19 minutes away yay you
get to see where I grew up
he likes hearing his name over and over
again
hey look up baby
you perfect you burped yeah you did
you see it noise wow that's a lot of
milk Express there how much is that
brand new breast pump so I got two of
these it's greatly no wires I love it
it's awesome this is a little more than
three ounces like 3.1 you got food boy
you got food
[Music]
we are 20 minutes away from home from
the birthplace of your father taking my
spawn to my birthplace
somehow it feels very important I guess
I I can't relate because he was born in
my birthplace true when he's happy he's
so cute yeah he's a happy baby oh
oh I see you
he's cute
he's too loud you're too loud get him
smile you look like Batman right now
Luca you're at your Dallas home welcome
you're basically here laughing how come
he's laughing there's Luca there's a
Luca left
how cute what it's the pictures that we
gave them for for help for wait what
Christmas oh yeah
if you're washing dishes and you watch
that yeah and then this came on because
it's motion right it came on we forgot
about the dishes we just like
I need to wash dishes
foreign
[Music]
I know you guys look great and I didn't
really plan ahead so I have an offshoot
of red which is pink
blue pineapple shorts and those aren't
just any shorts
they're so short so I'm ready for the
summer you know close enough to July 4th
they're close enough in college games
right yeah we're at a local neighborhood
um
Country Club and enjoying the
festivities here which is really cool
because um everyone's got golf uh golf
carts yeah I was like golf clubs it's
much hotter here than it is in
California that's for sure it's very
humid very suffocating being outside oh
my gosh you guys are so cute look at
this I just took a picture it looks so
cute yeah Isaac isn't here yet he's
actually joining us tomorrow he's flying
into Dallas all on his own in the
meantime though
it's just the three of us in terms of
this immediate family
who's that guy who's that guy you like
seeing yourself huh he loves seeing
himself yeah I don't think he knows him
he's like who's that baby smiling at me
he's always smiling back at me like my
mom has another baby in her arms in that
box
[Music]
you want to bite your toy
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
I think she's looking down yeah short
attention span you got bored of the
fireworks baby
all right it is the day after uh
Thanksgiving
Fourth of July
Fourth of July yeah
Independence Day and we decided mom was
gonna make me some food she wanted to uh
yes a home-cooked meal she wanted to uh
spoil her baby boy even though
I don't care you're so
[Music]
smell the smell I'm smelling right now
it smells like I ate in my childhood but
yeah this is what we got going on today
awesome chicken got some veggies we got
some shrimp we got some really rare
steak we got some steamed fish over here
as an appetizer we got some scallops and
a lobster tail oh really and this is my
favorite sauce of all time yes oh yeah
so excited and Luca's sleeping we got
him in the air airport so we
accidentally left the iPad in Vegas I
left it in the safety box thing whatever
the safe luckily Nikki picked it up for
me gave it to me in Austin so now we
have our iPad back which is what we use
to monitor Luca so anyway
and soup
[Laughter]
because they started drinking soups I
was like oh yeah soup I forgot to
highlight the soup
baby what are you doing here what are
you doing here tell him daddy it's gonna
be my first time in a swimming pool
thank you
you ready I'm about to go swimming in
the summertime look at my boys
look it up
it looks good Ernie
look at my baby boy he's fully protected
since he's too young to wear sunscreen
so I I got him his little outfit to
protect him from the Sun oh my baby he's
wearing a swim diaper which catches
pooping up pee the more you know
[Music]
oh
your first full experience wow look at
this like you're back in the womb
what do you think I think processing
like Computing
hi Daddy
what's up everybody
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]